[Music]
the quest for the throne is on the quest
for the throne is on da da da da da da
when you read the scenes there's a
journey in there and then I've got to
try and find a way to achieve what's on
the page and then make it interesting
you choreograph all this real action and
then I'm thinking okay how safe can I
make it I can put wire on them and decel
them I can bury a mat you know we're
trying to create this really dynamic
frame of action we'd love to go home at
the end of the day and you know no one's
paid any kind of price
[Music]
we've burned more people than anybody
else basically there is a bit of mental
preparation goes into these things but
it's really controlled it's a real
process we do lots of rehearsals where
we put the masks on people walk to where
we were gonna do the burn with the hands
on the shoulder their safety guys and we
line them all up we then really
methodically practice but what we've
caught like our fire dance which is when
you are then set on fire the the route
you take in the scene to where you then
lie down to be extinguished by the
safety guys so precautions are really
experienced we have guys covering them
at all times
we only burn them for 15 seconds because
that ensures that we're not going to
have any significant heat transfer they
wear three layers of Nomex underwear it
won't burn it won't melt like a man-made
fabric and that's soaked in a fireproof
gel we put into a fridge and so that's
taken down to almost freezing then they
put on a thin rain suit over the top
there's a fire suit on top of that then
a boiler soup to protect the fire suit
and then the costume so there's quite a
few layers going on the latex masks on
your face has got a really small hole
that you have to breathe through because
obviously when you're on fire you bite
down on that and that stops any fumes or
flame coming through the mask the aim of
it is to be really calm really relaxed
to get your heart rate down just listen
to every single word Rowley saying
because if you do then the shot will
work and everything will be fine
[Music]
the show's just keeps getting bigger
we need 73 for fire burns during new
truck we did 20 in one shot that was a
record for TV we didn't do it wantonly
to set a record I was aware of it
obviously and everyone likes that but
out you know it was for the shot that
was the shield wall and everyone get in
here so it had a purpose not just a
record
[Music]
it is a little stressful
but with all stunt work it's you it's
about harnessing that stress and
channeling it you know that kind of
energy fears really good fear will keep
you safe but you need to just channel
that fear and use that energy to achieve
what you want to achieve I wanted to
finish it there was no way I was not
going to come back for Season eight you
know but I think the story is nearly
ready to be completely told so that's so
it's mixed so it's a little bit into a
little bit sadness but proud that I've
been part of it for four years you know
I've done half of it and I've enjoyed
every moment of it you know so I will
always look back on this very fondly
hey everybody is Charlie they dropped a
couple new Game of Thrones Season 8
promos we break down there's also a
couple interviews that they did was to
Jorah talking about Jon Snow and
Daenerys there's something about Tyrion
so we'll break it all down this is just
their next phase of promotion as they
get closer and closer I am doing a new
round of the book giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video they're
also doing a special real-life treasure
hunt where you try to find an Iron
Throne it's six different places around
the world they're not really clear about
what happens if you actually find one of
the thrones if you win tickets to the
premiere or you win some special prize
or something like that but apparently
it's counting down for the next 15 days
or so which is well before the start of
the season so maybe in another 15 days
is when we'll get another really big
trailer but as you can tell most of this
promo is them showing you how they burn
people with the Dragons as they gotten
bigger and bigger each season they burn
more and more people setting a couple
records we burn more people than any
other TV show in creation right now this
is pretty awesome record to hold and
then you consider that the dragons are
even bigger during season eight I've got
a lot of questions about how much bigger
so we'll talk about that in a second but
this is jon snow fighting whites with
torment at hardhome not a whole lot of
burning going on during hardhome just
burning some of those shacks down but
white Walker stepping through it which
is still probably one of the coolest
shots that they had at that point in the
show the white that Jon Snow is fighting
during that action scene when he steps
through the fire is actually the same
actor in real life that's playing the
night King the last couple of seasons on
the show ever since season six for
whatever reason the actor who played the
night king up to hardhome didn't come
back for more seasons after that but you
do really notice the difference if you
watch hardhome then you go and you watch
all the season six episodes and all of a
sudden the night king looks completely
different like wait a minute what's
going on here they use a little bit of
footage from battle of the bastards
talking about the horse stunts this is
just when Jon Snow was getting ridden
down by the Karstark and the Bolton
horse riders I know a lot of people were
asking about the Dothraki during the
season a trailer whether or not there
were actually dire wolves in the
background here just because there are
so many who's running by some of the
legs in the background don't seem quite
big enough to be horse legs yes I do
think that we will see more dire roles
during season 8 but the only dire wolf
that they confirmed is coming back
officially is ghost so if Nymeria comes
back it will be a surprise but I've
already done a
explaining how george RR martin was
foreshadowing diarrhea super-pac being
important late in the game more of beric
Dondarrion fighting with his flaming
sword the Brotherhood without banners
when they were north of the wall in
season 7 we've seen him in the trailer
it's not really clear exactly where he
is just entering this castle it could be
somewhere further up in the north maybe
near the last horse or it could be them
back at Winterfell
there's no architecture here that
specifically places this in any
particular place in the north because ed
is with them this could still be one of
the different castles along the wall
they're just seeking refuge in from the
army of the dead there's a whole lot of
Lannisters being burned during the field
of fire during season seven I love that
the stunt performers call it their
quote-unquote fire dance like they're
performing the act of drogon burning
them and they're running around like a
bunch of fried chickens as far as we
know during season eight especially in
that first big battle with the knight
king's army the white walkers the whites
most of the people being burned will be
that giant white army with the Dragons
just cutting wide swaths through them
there are lot of theories though that
the knight King is going to swerve and
call an audible leave his white Walker
generals to fight the battle at
Winterfell and turn himself and try to
go down to King's Landing whether or not
he actually makes it to King's Landing
remains to be seen but that would be the
only way you actually see the golden
company actually get to do a really big
battle before the end of the season
because otherwise they're just gonna be
sitting there chilling out until Jon
Snow and Daenerys is remaining forces
make it south to deal with Cersei so you
guys can let me know in the comments do
you actually think that the night king
himself will do battle at Winterfell or
if he will just turn in head south to
King's Landing to try and get them to
fight a war on two fronts because that
would be a really easy way for him to
win because looking at some of these
promo pictures you actually see the
night king in front of this door here I
look twice some of the other photos in
the knocker there in the pattern of the
door is the exact same is the door here
in King's Landing behind Cersei when
she's sitting here so these are just
promo pictures it doesn't necessarily
confirm that the night king is actually
at the gates to King's Landing but that
would be a really cool twist because
there's one thing for them to have all
those combined forces at Winterfell they
do have a really strong chance of
winning but no matter how badass the
golden company is we don't have any
circe has anything at King's Landing
that's capable of killing the night king
she could probably use one of Qyburn
scorpions to bring down Vissarion but
that wouldn't kill the night king and
he's so powerful that he could just cut
right through any minor infantryman that
come at him turned them raised them back
up and his forces start to grow
exponentially and eventually you overrun
King's Landing with a bunch of whites
one of her other special moves that
she's had the last couple of seasons has
been wildfire there's no evidence in the
books right now that lets us know
whether or not wildfire is more
effective than regular fire against the
White Walkers and the whites because the
night King here is seen up north of the
wall during episode six walking right
through those flames and not even
batting an eye as if they don't affect
him so regular fire doesn't seem that
effective against him and remember this
actually isn't just regular fire it's
dragon fire so if dragon fire isn't that
effective against him that I don't know
how much more effective wildfire could
be it would just potentially burn a
little bit longer but I'm sure that he
has enough magic to put that fire out
pretty quickly talking a little bit
about the interviews that they just did
they did one with Serge or he talked a
little bit about Jon Snow and Daenerys
it's not quite as illuminating as I
would have hoped he mostly talks about
how sore Jorah feels about Daenerys and
what his position is in the Jon Snow
Daenerys of it all because so much of
the last couple of seasons has been
about bringing them together and then
now the suspense of waiting to see
what's gonna happen when they all find
out that Jon Snow is secretly a
Targaryen they're related in Daenerys
might be potentially pregnant so you
have a couple of these extra characters
like Jorah and Tyrion who at one time or
another had romantic feelings for
Daenerys so the actors just talked a
little bit about that the way that he in
Glens surgery explains it now is is that
after season four when she banished him
then he came back during season five won
her affection then had to leave her
again because of the greyscale then came
back during season seven by the time he
had come back all his desire for a
romantic relationship with Daenerys was
gone he was just happy to be in her
presence he registers that there's
something special going on between the
two of them he's mostly just supportive
of Daenerys he feels like Jon Snow is a
good match for her because he is the
king in the north so he's thinking about
it from more of a political angle and
just trying to serve her in the best
possible way and obviously he really
likes
on the field de bal that's why in the
season 8 trailer you see him on
horseback wielding hearts pain because
Samwell has apparently given it to him
so he will be wildung a Valyrian sword
during season 8 I've already talked a
little bit about Tyrians side and all
this because apparently Peter Dinklage
is like no he definitely has romantic
feelings for Daenerys he's a little
conflicted about it and he's a little
worried about how their relationship is
going to complicate the alliance in what
they have to do during season aid but
that's all he's really said about it he
hasn't said anything that's implied that
he would betray Daenerys but there are a
couple foreshadowing moments during
season 7 did imply that he's going to
have a real problem in assaulting Cersei
by the end of the season so if they're
any more clues for a Tyrion betrayal in
any of the season 8 trailers that we get
between now and then I'll talk more
about that but right now we don't have
quite enough evidence to confirm that
just to address the Dragons size issue
for those of you that are wondering how
much bigger drogon is they haven't given
official models for scale but if you
look at Jon Snow in Daenerys walking up
to drogon and Ragle what it looks like
here is that Rhaegar is about as big as
drogon was in drogon is maybe 25% 30%
bigger I wouldn't say he's double in
size because he was already really big
like look at how big they all are
sitting on top of drogon during episode
6 now his head looks big enough that
Daenerys could sit right behind his
horns and just grab his horns and use
those to stabilize herself when she's
riding him
there are a lot of you that have asked
about Jon Snow potentially riding regal
during season 8 I've already talked
about a couple scenes during the season
a trailer where I think that Jon Snow is
riding dragons and they just digitally
altered it or they haven't added his
character model to it so that you don't
know exactly what's happening so I'll
link that at the end of this
congratulations
Olly pop your the giveaway winner from
my last big Game of Thrones video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
my Game of Thrones Season 8 trailer
video about all the potentially
misleading scenes where Jon may or may
not be riding gray go and click here for
my really big night King Easter Egg
video thank you so much for watching
everybody
awesome I'll see you guys tonight